sentencing was friday for a former ohio
high school cheerleader accused of
killing her newborn daughter
two days after attending her senior prom
Brooke Skylar Richardson was acquitted
of the most serious charges including
murder but was convicted of abuse of a
corpse the judge told Richardson the
young woman had a grotesque disregard
for life after the infant's body was
found buried in Richardson's backyard
Richardson was 18 at the time I'm
forever sorry and I'm so sorry I I'm
really really sorry and I understand
Brookes Tyler Richardson emotional
before learning she would be sentenced
to three years of probation and seven
days in jail I can sometimes be selfish
but I would like to think that I've
become better than the knowledge that
I've upset everyone and hurt so many
people with what I've died the trial
began last week with prosecutors arguing
Richardson kept her pregnancy a secret
and never intended to keep her baby
Brooke took her own daughter's life
destroyed all evidence of her birth and
buried her in the backyard in an
interrogation room in 2017 she described
the events of the birth medical experts
testifying for both the prosecution and
defense agreed there was no proof the
baby was alive and it was that lack of
proof that prevented the jury from
convicting Richardson on the most
serious of charges we didn't have the
evidence to prove it beyond a reasonable
doubt because we could not present
medical cause of death the baby's
paternal grandmother spoke Friday she
says her family did not know about the
baby until long after the baby's death
every May 7 I don't get to have a
birthday party for my first grandchild
instead I get to some new balloons to
heaven with notes telling her how much
her daddy loves her how much I love her
how much would Oliver Richardson was
credited with time served so she walked
out of the courthouse on Friday if she
violates her probation she could spend a
year in jail